Welcome to the rusting Replit course. This
course will introduce you to the rust programming
language. With it in the description. There are
links to various materials used and mentioned in
this course. Specifically, there is a one click
link to the interactive course powered by rapid
which allows you to learn rust completely
within your browser. There is also a link
to the slides mentioned, which can be used
as a cheat sheet for us. Finally, there is a
link to an article written by yours truly, which
walks through rust and the interactive projects.
This course assumes intermediate knowledge
in at least one other programming language.
If you are new to programming, why not try
the interactive Free Code Camp curriculum.
This is an interactive course going over the
basics of the rust programming language within
your browser. First, you will get an overview
of rust. The course covers the basics of rust,
but you can also find some notes of
this in the linked slides or article.
Then you can follow the interactive
content to create your own CLI calculator.
Where you can perform basic arithmetic
operations through the command line.
Then you will create an image
combiner this project takes
two images and combines their pixels into
one new image. First an overview of rust.
A quote from the official rust book rusts deals
with low level details of memory management,
data representation and concurrency. The language
is designed to guide you naturally towards
reliable code that is efficient in
terms of speed and memory usage.
The main tooling within the rust ecosystem are
rusty, which is the compiler that takes your
rust code and compiles it into a binary which is
machine readable code rust up which is the command
line utility to install and update rust and cargo,
the rust build system and package manager which
you will get a lot of experience using throughout
this course. And now moving on to the first
project the CLI calculator. To begin, I have a
real built using the next language in Replit.
This allows me to define the necessary
tooling for the project. The link to this
template is available in the description
of this video. If you want to go too long.
You can use cargo to create a new Ross project in
the current working directory by typing in cargo
new followed by the project name,
which we will call calculator.
This creates a new directory named
calculator initializes it as a git repository
and add useful boilerplate for your project.
The cargo Tamil file is the manifest used by
cargo to manage your project metadata. This
is similar to a package dot json file if you
are familiar with those. The main.rs file is
the default entry point for your application.
You can see it contains a function declaration
using the FM keyword with the handle main
as well as a call to the print ln macro which
prints to the console in rust. A macro is
denoted by the exclamation mark character,
which is also known as the being symbol.
To run the project, navigate
into the calculator directory
then you can either use the cargo Run command
which will compile your code and
then run the compiled binary.
As you can see hello world is printed out.
Or you can use rust C which is the compiler
where you pass in an argument as the location
to your entry point file. In our case,
this is the source folder and the file is
main.rs. This will compile your code into a binary
and it will be placed within your working
directory then you can run the binary throughout
this project, I will just be using cargo to
run the project. So let's remove that file
the rust standard library
comes with an EMV module,
which allows access to the command line
arguments passed when calling the program.
The necessary exports from the
EMV module for this project
are the OGS function and the OG struct. The OGS
function returns an instance of the OG struct
and is imported into the file scope with the
following syntax use keyword followed by standard
the module name in V, the name of the
function OGS, and the name of the struct
To get an idea of what the abstract looks
like, you can declare a new variable named OGS
using the let keyword and assign the value
of the return of calling the function OGs.
Then, use the print line macro to
print the value of the OGS variable.
To do this, place curly brackets
within the string as the first argument
and pass the variable you want
to go within the curly brackets.
Now, if you run this code, you will
see the following error Augs cannot
be formatted with the default format. Because
the trait display is not implemented for OGs.
That's a lot to take in. But for now,
this error comes about because the print
line macro does not know how to format the
abstract. However, you can just follow the
compilers advice here to extend the format
using the code on question marks syntax.
Now, running this code, you
should be able to see the output.
As you can see, the abstract is printed to
the console. And it contains an inner field,
which consists of the location
of the compiled binary.
You can confirm this by running the
application and passing it an argument
Free Code Camp. Now we can see Free Code Camp
is in the inner Ray. When we ran our code,
you might have noticed that the compiler threw
a warning saying we have an unused import.
We don't strictly have to import hogs. But if
you want to explicitly type the OGS variable,
you can do so using the OG struct that we
imported like so. Now running the code,
that warning should no longer be there.
To access the arguments within the OG struct
within the OGS variable, you can use the Enter
method which exists on the OG struct. First,
let's declare a new variable named first.
And assign it the value of calling the Enter
method on OGs. Hovering over the method,
you can see the function definition where
it looks like it takes in two arguments.
However, being a method on a struct,
the first argument is implicit.
And is usually a reference to self where self
is the struct. In this case, this is a mutable
reference to self. argument that needs to be
passed in is in which is a use side a number
and it returns the nth element of the iterator
which is wrapped in an option. Let's unpack what
all of that means. So accessing the first argument
by passing zero is printed to the console.
You'll notice you will still get
an error if you run the code.
This error is saying that the OGS
variable cannot be borrowed as mutable.
We noticed that in the definition, the
nth method took a mutable reference to
in this case OGs. So, in order to use the method,
we need to declare OGS as immutable variable.
After doing that, we should
be able to run the code.
And this is what the first variable is value is it
is some wrapping the value we are interested in.
Some is a variant on the option enough. This will
become more clear as we define enums later on.
For now. Just know that you can unwrap options
to get the value inside. rerunning this code,
we should see that the value is
no longer wrapped in sum. However,
in this case, if we pass in an index where there
is no argument, running the code, you will see
that the application panic. Panicking is rust 12
erroring out during runtime. You can see three
main panics That called optional unwrap on a non
value. This is because when there is no value
to access using the end method, none is
returned, as opposed to some with a value.
So instead of unwrapping,
let's just print that value.
And first the variable is none. And and none
has no value, therefore, it cannot be unwrapped.
To fix this, let's get the first argument out.
And once again, unwrap now running our code,
you will see that we get Free Code Camp.
We know we want our application to take in
three arguments, first being the first number,
as well as an operator being plus times divide,
or minus. And this will be the next argument.
Let's unwrap that as well as a third
argument being the second number.
To get an idea of all of these, let's print them
out to the console. First operator and second.
Running this, let's add some arguments. We would
expect to use this application by going one
plus two for example. However
running this, our application panics
apparently, we are still unwrapping on a non
value. Well, which of these is the non value, it's
keep adding arguments to find out. Application
still panics for the application and still
panics. Now we are passing six arguments in its
application and it is still cranking that add more
finally, the application doesn't panic.
And this is because the nth method
returns an element of an iterator
and we know it needs to be the iterates over
the OGS variable. Internally what this means is
the nth method will look something like this
when we have a mutable reference to self
as well as n, which is the use size or the
index. And we know this returns an option
where it is either a string of the value we
want or not. Now South Quino is our OG struct.
But what nth does is for each n we can assume
N in this case as an example, assume it equals
zero. So we are accessing the first element.
There is some sort of iterator over self.
Accessing let's see that in array
and it is calling next on that array.
As you can see next advances the
iterator and returns the next value.
So, in accessing the first element
when the method is called a second time
the iterator has passed the first element.
So that second call calling next again
will result in the second element being passed.
Let us look at it from this
perspective. If at this point in her
is equal to an array of these two arguments.
Calling next brings up the first argument.
Cooling next again, would
bring up the second argument
So, as we are unwrapping here,
and let's get rid of this
as we are unwrapping the variable into first,
which in the case of our call would be one,
calling the method again on to this time
starts at the plus argument, and two becomes
the first element after that. And then three
is the second index of the iterator. Practice
Practically, this means if we want to
access the elements we are interested in
what we actually need to do when we are calling
just this code. And we don't want it to panic.
We want the first indexed element.
Running this should yield what we
want. Now, unlike some other languages,
you cannot perform basic arithmetic operations
on strings. And all of these variables that we
have here are strings. So we need to parse them
into numbers, or inoculate in our case floats.
So we can declare a new variable first number,
and set that equal to first which is a string,
use the past method on the string,
which we can see here returns a result.
And a result is similar to the option enum in
that it can be unwrapped to get the value out.
And we can do the same for the second number
to be second, dot pass dot unwrap.
Now, we should get a warning that rust doesn't
know what type we want the number to be,
because there are many kinds of numbers in Rust,
we need to give it a type annotation.
And we can do this in many ways. One
is to annotate the variable this way
in which case the parse method knows
to take second as a string and parceled into
NF 32. All my preferred method for doing this
is to use something called turbo fish
syntax, which is fun to use and fun to say.
This can be done because on the parse method
you can see it accepts F which is the type
and it returns a result of that type.
So, let's change second number to that as well.
Now, let us declare a new function called
operate and this will take in the operator
and we can have the operator of
your car which is the type character
we will need the first number which we know is
in F 32. And the same with the second number
now we can use a bunch of if
statements to compare if the operator
is equal to the character we
expect for example, in this case,
the addition character and what we can do
is return first number plus second number.
Now, first thing that we
will come across is an error
that there are mismatched types which expected an
empty tuple but found an F 32. And this is because
we have not added a return type annotation to
the function we can do that with this syntax.
Another thing to note is the type car in Rust This
is a character literal made using single quotes.
Whereas if we had used double quotes
that would be of the type string
let's continue with this logic. Adam an else
if statement. Comparing if operator is equal to
a minus. Then we can return
first number minus second number
else if operator is equal to divide by
then return first number divided by second
number. And finally, the last operation we'll need
is if operator is equal to an asterix,
or the multiplication operator
we will get a warning that we
don't have all of our clauses,
where the if statement is missing an
else clause. This is because in Rust
if the operator did not match any of those, then
the function will return an empty tuple. And as
we have typed the function to return an F 32, it
cannot return an empty tuple. So we add the base
case otherwise, return for now we can just return
zero. But you'll notice you cannot just type zero
because it expects an F 32. And
floats require the decimal place.
Something else to note about rust
is it allows implicit returns.
What this means is you can get rid of the return
keyword as well as the semicolon at the end. And
this is exactly the same as what we had
before. But this is the more recitation
way of writing the code. And we can do this
throughout. Now, to use the function operate,
you can declare a new variable called result.
Call the function passing in the
operator first number and second number.
However, you'll notice that we get a
warning because operators have type string,
but the function expects the type car.
So we need to convert the operator into
a character. And we can do this by using
the cost method on the string, which returns an
iterator over the characters of a string slice.
And with the iterator we can call the next
method to access the first element of that slice.
And the next method returns an option which
we know we can unwrap if the value exists.
Now, we can print our result let's run the
code to see if this all works as expected.
And we can see one plus two, the result is equal
to three. However, this is not the final output we
want. And what we can do is declare a new function
called output which will accept the first number
which we know to be an F 32 The operator which
is a car the second number which is also an F 32.
And then the result which is that operation
on the two numbers which is an F 32.
We will want this to return a string
and in order to get the output the way you
want, we can use the format macro, which is
very similar to the print line macro in that the
first argument is a reference to a string size
which we can pass in additional arguments
which will be placed within the curly brackets.
So we want first number operator, second number
is equal to result and format returns a string.
Now to use this what we can do is
call output and pass in first number.
The operator the second number and the result
Hopefully running the code gets us what we expect.
And that's correct, one
plus two is equal to three.
Let's try something else. Let's
try one minus two, negative one.
However, there's something much better we can
do to improve the readability of the code.
And that is instead of a
bunch of elsif statements,
we can use rusts pattern matching
expression, which starts with match fall
followed by the expression to be evaluated,
which in our case is the operator and then
this is called a match arm. And what this is,
is if cooperating matches the plus character
then evaluate the following
first number plus second number.
Now, because we are not
including a semicolon at the end,
this is implicitly returned and
we can continue with this logic.
Now, we will get an error, saying that we have a
non exhaustive pattern. Because similarly to the
if statements, they need, where we needed an else
clause, the match expression needs a base case,
which can be represented by the underscore
and we can still return the 0.0.
And you will see that this code
runs exactly the way it did before.
However, returning zero if the operator
is invalid, does not make too much sense.
So it might make more sense to panic. And you
can do that using the panic macro and pass it a
message such as invalid operator used. Now what
this will do is if an invalid operator is used,
the code will panic. You can see it
has panicked at invalid operating used.
But now, what if we wanted
to extend our application
to not just accept more multiplication?
What's the server say? This is an
interesting case where we need to escape
the Asterix. In order to run the code.
To get around that, you can extend the operator
function to not just work with an asterix, or not
just match with an asterix, which needs to be
escaped each time. But it is common to multiply
with an x. And we can extend it further using
bitwise OR for capital X. What this allows,
is instead of escaping the Asterix, we can
just use x to represent multiplication.
And this will work just fine. And that is our
application finished. All that's left to do
is build it and to do so you can use cargo
build to compile the binary and you can
also pass the release flag. What this
does is it provides some optimizations
for the compiler and removes all debugging
information running this will compile our code.
The code is found in the target
directory in the release directory
and it is called the binaries name.
We can run this code now with arguments
add the period at the beginning
and that we get the same result. So
that is the CLI calculator finished.
For the image combiner project, start by creating
a new rust project using the Cago new command.
And let's call this combiner then
cd into the combiner directory
and run the project to ensure
it is set up correctly.
You should see hello world printed to the
console. This project is bigger and more
complex than the calculator project.
So to prevent this The main.rs file
from becoming too overwhelming, create a new
file within the source directory called arcs.rs.
This file will be a new module named arcs, which
will house the logic used to handle the command
line arguments. Within arcs.rs create a function
named get enter arg which takes a U size in
and returns a string. Then, we know from
the previous project that we can access the
EMV module inside the standard
library and call the arcs function
chaining the nth method to get the nth
argument. And let's unwrap the value.
Now, to group the related command line argument
data, you can create a struct named OGs. You've
already encountered structs in the previous
project. This was the string struct and the struct
from the EMV module. Instead of using the NV OG
struct, you will be defining a custom arc struct
specifically for use in this application.
The string struct looks something like this
where we can declare the struct using the
keyword struct that contains the Vic field,
which is a veck of uate Vic, in this
case is a dynamically sized array.
So following this syntax
create a struct named Augs.
The three fields image one which is a string,
Image two, which is also a string and output
to also be a string, these will be the paths to
the images passed as arguments within main.rs.
The OG struct can be imported once the OGS file
is declared as a module using the mod keyword.
So mod OGS declares the file as a module and
then we can import it using the use keyword.
You can use the arc struct by declaring
a new variable named arcs in this case
and assigning it the value of the arcs followed
by the field name and values for those fields.
You will notice the error saying we cannot
use OGS here because it is not public.
It is a private field in a private struct
it is a private struct to make it public use
the pub keyword before the struct definition
now you will notice that each of the fields
is also private. So similarly before each
definition, the public key word can be used
to declare the field as public and therefore
accessible outside of the current module.
As you can see here to create a new
string the new function has been used.
The reason this function can be used
is because it has specifically been
implemented for the string struct the
implementation would look something like this.
Where function new has been declared
To be implemented on the string struct,
where it returns self being string. And as
you can see a string is created within it
and implicitly returned. And the same goes
for the new function within the veck struct.
Now, if you're creating many OG structs, it
would be beneficial to be able to do the same
thing that is implement a new function
on the OG struct within the OGS module.
So you can use the imple keyword to
implement new on the struct OGs. We
new does not take in any
arguments, no to return self.
Where we can take that code
we had previously here.
This time, returning it from the new function,
then we can call Augs. New to instantiate a new
org, you'll notice that there is again an error
that new is private. So before the function
declaration, use the public keyword to make the
new function public. If we were to print out
the value of ocsea You'll notice two
things. First being that there is an error,
which we've encountered before saying that
the treat display is not implemented for OGs.
Now, you may think that you could just
extend this as we have done previously.
However, we still get error, where the debug trait
is not implemented for arcs. In order to implement
the debunker trade, we can actually follow
the compilers advice here to add this syntax
to the struct definition, what this does,
this is an attribute that is deriving
the debug trait for the OG struct. And after
doing this, we should be able to print out
the OG struct. However, you'll notice that
currently, the fields are all empty strings.
This is not what is needed for the OGS fields. So,
we can replace the string new
call with the get end org function
passing in one as argument to the
first chord because the zeroeth
argument is the path to the
binary continuing this logic
we can pass in to to get the second argument
and similarly three to get the third argument
now if we run our code should get an error
because we are not passing in any any arguments.
So calling unwrap within the get nth
OG function should cause a panic.
What we can do is test this by calling
our application with some arguments.
And as we can see, image one has the
value first image to second and output
third. For this application, an external crate
called image is required to decode and encode
the images. Much the same way other languages have
libraries or packages. Rust has crates you can add
the image creator to application by creating
a new dependency in the Kaga dot Tamil file
this is the name of the crate followed by
its version number in our case 0.2 3.1 For
now, running cargo run will
fetch and install the image crate
whilst the image creators installing
a new function can be created within
main.rs named find image From path
we'll take an argument path, which is a
string. And we will set the return later.
The image crate comes with an IO
module, including a reader struct,
we can create a new variable Image Reader
set that equal to the reader struct.
And the struct implements an open function which
takes a path to an image file and returns a result
containing the reader. So, we can pass in the
path as the argument and we can unwrap the result
this reader can be formatted and decoded to yield
the image format for example, a PNG or a JPEG
as well as the image data
and new variable image format
will be assigned the unwrapped value of the dot
format method on the reader the imagery to being
the variable Image Reader dot format and we
can unwrap the value from within the format
and variable image can be assigned and unwrapped
value of the decode method on the reader.
Now, we are interested in both the
image and the image format variables.
So the two values can be returned in a
tuple. The image as well as the image format
can be returned in a tuple. To get an idea of the
types we need to return, we can explicitly type
our variables we know this to be a reader, but the
reader as a type of a BufferedReader from a file
the image format is also a type from
the image create which is image format.
And the image another type from the
image create which is a dynamic image.
So, we know we need to return a tuple from this
function and in the order to be a dynamic image
and an image format
then, the necessary imports can
be included at the top of the file
that is importing from the image
create the reader is in the IOE module
and from the image create the
dynamic image and the image format
you'll most likely get these errors until crater
has been installed. Now within the main function
the return tuple can be D structured
into two new variables which we will call
image one and image format
one from find image from path
parsing in the image one field from the OG
struct and the same can be done for image two.
You will notice the error about missing imports
for the explicit types within find image from
path. The BufferedReader and file structs
need to be imported from the standard library.
BufferedReader is within the IO module.
And file is within the FS module.
There is an error here in the print line
statement. But for now, we can get rid of that
line because we won't be using it. It is important
to handle errors which are likely to arise such
as the case where three images of different
formats are given as arguments to combine.
For example, we will need some logic where if
image one format is not equal to Image two format,
then only to return an error as well way of
handling such an error is to return a result
we have encountered some results already.
But a result can consist of either an okay,
or an error variant. What that practically
looks like is if we find the format's are
not equal to each other, we return
an error normally with a value within
what this means is our function
needs to be typed to return a result
and that result needs to contain some values.
But we also need the base case where if there
is no error of function returns okay, it is
common to see results return an empty tuple
when there is no error, what this means
is our result the type returned on okay
is an empty tuple. Otherwise, it will
be some error, the error we will return
is an enum and this is because enums are
useful for acting as both types. And as well
for now we can call our error as an image data
error. And we will need to define this enum.
To do so, we use the enum keyword
followed by the name of our enum
as well as the different variants on Ina. We
have seen this for example, with the option email
which is defined similarly to this where it
takes some with a value or it just returns none.
In our case, we will define one of the
variants to be different image formats.
As such, we can turn in within our main
function an error of image dot errors.
The variant different image formats, we just need
to fix this year image format one image format to
to make combining the images easier, the largest
image is resized to match the smallest image first
in to find the smallest image which we can do
using a function called Get smallest image
or get smallest dimensions I should say.
Because the image will consist of
two dimensions, each image will have
in this case, it will be a tuple containing
the width as a U 32. And the height as a U 32.
And the second image we will pass in its
dimensions which will be the same to use 30 twos
in a tuple what we will want to do is return
the smallest dimension as a tuple to compare the
sizes, we can declare one variable variable being
the number of pixels in the first dimension,
which will be the first dimension access the
first element in that tuple multiplying by
the second element in the same tuple and
we can do the same with the second tuple.
Now what we are comparing is the number of
pixels in the image. To do this we will return
if the number of pixels in the first image is less
than the number of pixels in the second image,
then we will return the first
image is dimensions else
the second image is dimensions we will
create a function called standardize
size which will take in the first
image which we know to be a dynamic
image as well as the second image
which again is a dynamic image
and it will return both images. We
can again return them in a tuple
however, these images will be resized. And
what we want is Using our get smaller dimension
function, we want to return the smallest with
the smallest height. So, we're creating two
new variables by destructuring the
return of get smallest dimension
passing in image one getting its
dimensions by using the dimensions method
available on the dynamic image
struct and the same with Image two.
Except this is good smallest dimensions there
you go, I think it is helpful if we print out
the values of the width and the
height which we can do like so
and we can also add a new line at the end
now, what we want to do is in order
to standardize the size, we will first
find out if for example, Image two steam
engines are equal to the width and the height
that we got from calling get smallest dimensions
on the image, then we will know that image two
is the smallest image and therefore, what we
want to do is we will want to resize image one
and we can use the Resize exact method which
is implemented on the dynamic image struct.
immutably borrows the image and using
the width, height and phototype arguments
resizes the image so, we can pass in the
width that we want the height that we want.
And now we need to pass in a filter type.
This type also comes from the image crate
and the type we will be wanting to use is
triangle this is just used for its simplicity
as well as it generally does a very good job of
resizing the image without distorting it too much.
Now, we will need to import triangle
it exists in the image drops
filter type number and it is the type of
triangle now, we are wanting to return a tuple
with the resized images. So, what we can
do is after resizing the first image,
we will then also just return Image two along with
it in a tuple and we will need an else clause that
is if image one is the smaller image then return a
tuple with image one unchanged, resizing Image two
passing in the new width we want the new height
and the filter type. You can see there are errors
about using the dimensions method on the
dynamic image and this is because the
trade has not been brought into scope. So,
we can follow the compilers advice to get
the generic image view treat
from Image generic image view
and that should be enough to get rid of the errors
for now, fixing the typo in the standardize size
functioning we can then have to claim the
format declare image one image two again
this time destructured from the standardize
size function having resized whichever image is
the largest. Now it is all in fine that we have
we are handling resizing the images. However, we
know that the end goal is to create a new image
Using the pixels from the two input images.
So to handle the output, a temporary struct
can be created to hold the metadata for the output
image. And we can call this struct floating image.
And the metadata we will want is the
width as a U 32. The height as a U 32.
It will contain some data being
the pixel values as a veck of uate.
Because the pixel values will exist between
zero and 255, AQa to perfectly fits that
number type. We also want the name of the image as
a string. In order to create this floating image,
we can do as we did previously with the old
struct and we can implement the new function
which will take in a width and a height
as well as the name and it will return a new
floating image. And what this will look like
is floating image with a value
of the input width and height.
We know that there will be some sort of data
as well as the name for the data. When we create
the new floating, we won't have the pixel values
yet, but we will need to reserve the space
for them in memory. In order to do this,
we can declare a buffer and that buffer could be
a fixed value, such as et Cie buffer capacity,
set this to some number, for example 3,655,744.
And then the buffer itself will be a vector
with the capacity of that buffer capacity
and then we can assign the buffer to the Stata. An
interesting thing about rust is that you can use
this number format to make your numbers easier
to read, where you separate three digits of your
number using an underscore. However, what we have
here assumes that any image we input will not be
larger than essentially this number of bytes that
we can more dynamically size this, based on the
fact that we know that our image will consist
of a height, you can multiply that by the width.
And to get the number of pixels, we multiply this
by four. The reason for this will be clearer as
we go through this next we will be using RGB a
values. So we are multiplying by four because
there we are using the red to green, the
blue and the alpha values for each pixel.
You will see we have a warning here that there are
mismatched types with capacity function expected
to use size but found a u 32. The reason but
capacities of type U 32. It's because we use
the height and the width to create it which are
you 30 twos. Normally, freshmen automatically
convert or trying to convert the number type into
the correct type. However, in this case, we cannot
be certain that this is possible. So we can follow
the advice the compilers giving to try to convert
the value. Otherwise, if that's not possible,
fail or in this case panic. So we can try into
and then unwrap. However, in order to use the
train method, we need to bring it into scope
and it exists in the standard library and the
Convert module of the tray into implementation.
So we can just bring that into scope. Now
within main we can create an output variable
containing the new floating image. We will
use image ones with and image one's height
as the inputs for the new function. We could use
Image two as well. But considering image one and
Image two have been resized to be the same size
the width and height will be identical anyway.
And we will want to pass in the output field from
the OG struct. As this will be the name of the
function and the location which we will later use.
At this point, we can deal with the error that we
have occurred, which is saying that the trait
debug is not implemented for image data areas.
We can resolve this by following compilers advice
to use the attribute and derive the debug trait
for our image dot two areas a number. The reason
this is necessary is because main returns the
standard output the result of running the code
normally either being a status of one or zero.
And in order to return to the
standard output, the debug trait
is to be derived. From here, we can run our code
to see if everything is working as expected.
What we will need are two images as inputs to
get these images, I will just be importing them
into our combine a project. Within the images
folder we have three images here. First being
my profile picture. The other being the
Free Code Camp blogger on the other end
inverted Free Code Camp logo
that we might use later.
Then in order to test our code, we can go Cago
run passing in the arguments which we know to be
images folder, we can pass in my profile image
as well as the image to the Free Code Camp.
But these images are PNGs we also need to
specify an output location which we can say
is within images. And we can set it to test a
PNG we have not currently implemented anything
for the output image to go into However,
we still need to provide the argument
get a few warnings
code panic because I called
the wrong folder nigga.
Running again we can see that
the width and the height output.
So everything is working as expected.
As I said earlier, in order to process images,
they are converted into a vector of RGB pixels.
And pixels are stored as you eight because
the values are between zero and 255.
So in order to process our images, we will be
creating a new function called combine images.
And this will take an image one,
which we know to be a dynamic image
image to the same and this will
return their cookie weights.
The dynamic instruct implements the to RGBA
method, which returns an image buffer containing a
veck of UAT. And the image buffer implements the
into vac method which returns the back itself.
So to visualize that a bit better, let's
declare a new variable called veck one which
will be image one we will call the to RGBA eight
method on the dynamic image you'll notice that
it returns an image buffer containing an RGB
you eight as well as the back of your eight.
So in order to get the backs out, we can
call the into BEC method on the image buffer.
Likewise, we can do for vector in image to
in processing our images, we will want to
alternate the pixels of the two images. So
what we will do is we will create a function
called alternate pixels. And what
this will do taking the two vectors
and it will return a vector of us
for us. So let's define that function
we know that it takes in too thick of
UAT. It also returns a vector view ID. First, we
need to declare a variable Java can combine data
that will hold the data of the two images after
they have been alternated, in essence, where we
are pushing the pixels from one vector and
then putting the pixels from the next vector.
And in order to size, the combined data,
we will match it using a VAC macro,
we want you weights. And we want the number
of your weights to be the same length
as any of the vectors passed. In this case,
they are the same, but we will just set them
to be the size of the first vector, what this
reg macro does, it will create for example,
if Vic one dot length is equal
to 100, or let's say five,
then the veck macro will create a vector
of have you rates of that same length.
Now, what else we will do
is we will use a while loop
to go over each pixel. In this case, we
will refer to the pixels as indices within
the length of the vector. And first, we
will need to declare this pi variable.
And we will know that we'll want to mutate
our variable so we'll declare it as a mutable
variable starting at zero and within
the while loop, we will increment
by four this is done because we are using
our GPA sets within the vector and being
four values we need to increment i by four as
we axing accessing the indices within the vector
using the modulo operator, we can see that
if I modular eight is equal to zero, we will
splice into combined data
the RGBA set from FX one,
in order to do this, we need to set the
range in our case the range will be from I
until I plus three and we will need to
get the RGBA set from the first vector.
To do this, we will create a little
function set GBA what this will do, it
will take in the first vector, it will take in
a starting index as well as an ending index and
it will return the RGBA Tet from those indices.
Otherwise, we will want to do similarly this time
passing in vector
so, let's define that set RGBA function
we know that it takes in a vector
this vector will be evaluates to
have a starting index, which is you size as well
as an end index also a new size, we will want to
return the vacuolated. In order to do this,
we will be declaring a mutable vector RGBA.
It's just a new vector. And for every index in
start until the end inclusive,
you will declare any variable
Val we will set this equal to Feck dot get and
pass in the index that we are interested in.
Then, after doing that, we will
push that index to the RGBA vector.
We will push that value and then we will want
to return that vector we have initially here
we get returns an option. What we could
do, it's just unwrapped to get the value.
However, there is a chance that that value
doesn't exist. So what would actually be better
is for us to match on get cool. And if there
is some value. It's called bad value d.
What we want to do is return the value
If there is none, what we want to do
is potentially panic and say
that the index is out of bounds.
Now, you will notice that we get an error, telling
that the function expected to return a vector of
the rates but instead is returning an empty tuple.
To resolve that, we can return the combined data.
You'll notice we have an issue here where combined
data is being spliced. So what we actually need
to do is declare it as mutable. And we get an
error down here saying that it expected function
is expected to return evaluates however, it is
actually returning a veck of UAT. But the UAT
are referenced. What this means is we are pushing
reference values. In this case, currently, Val
is equal to a reference of UAT. What we want is
for it to be just a UAT. In order to do that,
we can use the Asterix before the variable
what this does is dereference the value
that resolves the error, however, now we
have a new error, saying that the borrow
of a moved value back one where the value
borrowed after being moved. Here, we can see that
vac one has been moved. Why this is is because
within the while loop, we are passing Vic one
into the set RGBA function, we don't actually
want to pass in the whole value, what we want
to do is we want to pass in a reference to a
value pointer. And the same needs to be done.
With back to now we need to adjust the function
definition as it's not accepting back you at
accepting reference to evaluate. To clarify. The
syntax here is rusts range syntax, which allows
the range to be inclusive of the end value.
So far, we haven't called these functions yet.
However, what we need to do first is to set
the data of bind data into the output image
which we actually need to call output. A method
on floating image needs to be defined to set
the data field of the output to the value of
that combined data because currently what we
have for the data field is just a buffer not
the actual pixel values we are interested in.
So far, you have only defined functions on struct.
However, now we are wanting to define a method
methods are defined in a similar way, but they
take an instance of the struct as their first
argument. You saw this with the next method.
So we are going to define a method called
set data on the floating image. What this
will do is with we'll take a mutable reference
to self as well as the data we are wanting
to set which is effectively weights.
What this will do is return a result
either on okay to return an empty tuple or to
return one of our image data error. Variance
what we can do is first make sure
that data dot length is greater than
the current floating images capacity.
If the length of the data is more than the
capacity of the current floating image, what
this means is we cannot store we did not reserve
enough buffer in order to store that data. So
here we will return an error.
And this type of error will be
image dot errors. And we'll need to
declare a new variant and this will be
buffered to small. So we need to do to
find that variant to buffer to small.
Otherwise, we can just set the data to
the data that is passed into the method.
In that case, the result is okay. Now within
main, we can call that method on output.
Passing in the combined data. You'll
notice that again only one argument is
passed into set data because implicitly
the first argument of a method is self.
You need to define combined data. Let's
do that first and say that combined data
equal to we have the combine images function.
And it takes in image one and Image two.
And what we've done is we've made that set dotta
returns a result. And the interesting thing you
can do with the rest is propagate that result
fairly, by adding a question mark at the end of
the expression. What this will do is essentially
unwrap the value but it's propagated into
current function and as main already returns
a result of either Okay, with an empty tuple,
or an error with image data errors, which
is the same function signature as set data,
we can use error propagation operator. Finally,
the new image needs to be saved to a file,
the image create has a safe buffer with
format function, which works like this.
We can use safe buffer. With format, we need to
pass in the path of where we want to save the
image, which we have stored in the Name field of
output, we need to pass in the data from output.
However, this needs to be a reference to
the data and not passing the value itself.
resizing the width of the new
image. And the height of the image
needs to define the color type of the image,
we can get the color type from the image
create. And we know that the type is RGBA.
And they are you eight. And finally the format
of the image, which will be the same as image
one format. This function also returns a result
so we can unwrap that. And I need to remember
to correctly name my variables, you'll
see we still get an error about output,
where we can offer it as mutable because there's
not declared it mutable. This is because inside
data as a method, it takes a mutable reference to
self, which in this case is output. So we need to
declare our output variable has been beautiful.
To test out our image combiner we can once again
cover run and pass in arguments, which
we know to be images to my profile PNG
images to the FCC glyph. And we output
this image into the images folder.
And we will call it output dot png.
Running this will compile the code.
And once it has finished, we should be able
to navigate into that images folder and
find the output. And there it is the profile
image. And if we go can bluff combined into
one image. Although the application is finished,
we have a lot of calls to unwrap within our code.
What this means is if at any point there is an
error during runtime, our code will panic. And it
may not provide the best user experience all the
best error to help develop and debug as they're
using the application. So, one thing we can do to
extend this as we already have some basic error
handling within our main function, where we are
returning result where if there are any errors,
we are returning image data areas, which is
enough we can extend this further with some
more common types of error. So, for example,
fixing up the find image from path function
instead of unwrapping on the reader open
returns a result. So, what we can do is
we can match on the result and if the
expression is okay, we will get the Image Reader
otherwise, if there is an error, we can get this
error out in a variable named E and then we can
return an image data error and we will add
a new type of unable to read image from path
as a variant on image dot areas you know
and we can pass an E as a value to the INA.
So let us define this New variant
we named it unable to read image from path
and we know it takes in some sort of error.
Now, this error exists in the standard library as
standard IO error. Next, we need to move our logic
within this match on that we can continue
with the next unwrap statement. However,
format returns an option. And the general rule
of thumb I follow with how to handle options
versus results is as we have already done with
a result we match on the result and we handle
the okay variant versus the error variant.
However, if we are dealing with an option
what I like to do is use an if let statement and
that looks something like this. If let there is
a value that is the option returns some then we
can declare a new variable called image format.
And if this is the case, we can perform
some logic else we can return an error
in this case, you'll need to explicitly
return error image data errors and we will
declare a new variant called unable to format
image and something we can do here is pass in
the path that way our error has more information
with it as to which image that failed to read.
Now, we cannot pass in part as is because we are
moving at into this open call. So what we need to
do is passing a reference to the path to the first
open call and then we can define that variant
and we call that variable unable to
format image and it took in a string
then handling the image logic as decode
returns a result we can match on the result
match on the result and in the arms. If okay, we
can get the value in a variable called image we
can return okay with the tuple that we expect
to be an image as well as the image format.
Otherwise, if there is an error, we can get
the error in a variable called E and return
that error in again another
variant of image data errors
and this variant we will call unable to decode
image and we will pass in that error as is. So,
to declare this new variant, which we named unable
to decode image, it takes in a specific error from
the image crate which is called Image error.
As such, we need to add it to our dependency
then we can remove some of this
logic that we are no longer using
and means to fix up some things. So, we need
to define our function to return a result
and on this result, it is either returning a
tuple which we originally had otherwise that
you know it is returning one of the image data
areas variance then as we learned earlier earlier,
we can propagate the errors into the main function
as we are calling it using the error propagation
operator. And finally, we have one more unwrap
to deal with and this is on the safe buffer
with format function. Now, what we can do with
this is as it is returning a result however,
we are only actually interested in the case where
there is an error, we will again use an if let
expression de structuring the error from the call.
This way, we can just return the error if there is
one in a new variant called unable to save image
and passing that error. Otherwise we can return
okay To define that variant, which we named unable
to save image, and we are passing in, again,
an image error from the image creator, we have
also reject this to no longer be using these
imports. So what we can do is just remove that.
And just like that they are handling our
areas in a much better way to inform both
the developer and all the final user of what
is happening when any of these areas arise.